hey everyone it's the Earth registered
nurse rn.com and in this video I'm going
to be covering fluoroquinolones so let's
get started fluoroquinolones also known
as quinolones for short are a group of
antibiotics that are really good at
targeting gram negative and
gram-positive bacteria so some of the
gram-negative bacteria can Target
includes hemophilus influenzae which is
a cause of epiglottitis in young
children and other respiratory
infections it can also Target nyseria
gonorrhea which causes gonorrhea
chlamydia E coli klebsiella pneumoniae
salmonella and pseudomonas araginosa the
gram-positive bacteria that this group
targets includes streptococcus
pneumoniae especially the newer
quinolones and this includes the ones
that have the little pink star beside of
them which we're going to go over here
in a moment and enterococcus and
staphylococcus aureus now because
quinolones can treat a wide variety of
bacteria they're really good at treating
cases of urinary tract in infections
skin infections respiratory infections
sexually transmitted infections and then
infections that affect the abdomen joint
and Bones now let's talk about how
quinolones are administered and how you
can identify if your patients taking a
quinolone so typically these medications
are given orally because they're
absorbed very well in the gut but we can
also give them parentally if we need to
so for identification purposes whenever
you're looking at your patient's
medication list they tell you they're on
an antibiotic this is the name how can
you tell that this is a fluoroquinolone
well remember the word floxacin and that
is what you're going to find in that
generic name of this group of
antibiotics so we're talking about
fluoroquinolone which begins with FL and
we're talking about remember floxacin
and notice FL is in all of those so if
you can remember floxacin you're dealing
with fluoroquinolones try to make that
connection in your mind and you'll just
never forget it so some of these
medications include o floxacin
norfloxacin
ciprofloxacin Gemma walks Us in
levofloxacin and this was my favorite
one to say it's moxifloxacin and
delafloxacin and then here as I pointed
out earlier these ones with the pink
little stars these are the newer ones in
this group so now let's talk about how
this group of antibiotics Works to treat
bacterial infections so with
fluoroquinolones what they do is they
have a bacterial subtle effect on the
bacteria meaning that they actually kill
these bacteria instead of having a
bacteriostatic effect like some of the
other antibiotics we've talked about in
this series where they inhibit its
growth or reproduction instead these
just kill them dead they're they're not
going to fool around so how they do this
is that they inhibit the bacteria's DNA
replication process and bacteria knows
in order for it to continue surviving in
its environment it has to make copies of
itself so how it does this is it makes
copies of its DNA and remember DNA is
like the instruction manual for a living
organism it tell that organism how to
function how to reproduce and survive so
it has to make copies of this and
there's many enzymes that play a role in
this replication process and
fluoroquinolones Target two particular
enzymes that I want you to remember
one enzyme is called DNA gyrase and then
the other type is topoisomerase IV so to
help us understand how quit alone's work
let's first simplify the process of how
this bacteria undergoes DNA replication
hence makes copies of itself and then
talk about how fluoroquinolones come
along and disrupt some of this process
and in the end kills our bacteria so
here whenever we have double strand DNA
it looks similar to this we have one
strand here and then we have another
strand here it's like wrapped around
itself well in order to replicate hence
make copies of itself those strands have
to separate so we can get some copies
made so in order to do this an enzyme
comes in called helicase and separates
these strands so you have one hanging
out here and one hanging out there then
what comes behind that is another enzyme
called DNA polymerase it comes in and
makes copies so it slides up and down
this Strand and makes a beautiful copy
here and then makes another beautiful
copy here
now as this was happening this other
part of the Strand that wasn't separated
has started to in a sense get tightly
wound around itself we call this it's
become super coiled now we need to
alleviate this super coiledness of this
strand because we need these parts to
fold over so we can continue with this
replication process so an enzyme is
going to come in called DNA gyrase and
it's going to help alleviate this
tightness this super coil that's
happened so how it does is it's going to
like slice and reconnect parts of it it
loosens it up so once we have the role
of DNA gyrase complete these newly
copied daughter DNA strands are going to
fold over
now as they fold over we have the
beautiful copies but there's a problem
they're still connected and they need to
separate so they can go on do their own
thing and make more bacteria so we need
them to separate in order to separate
the enzyme topoisomerase 4 is going to
come in and it separates it so when we
throw on a fluoro quinolone it can
disrupt this process and how it does
this it really depends on if we're
dealing with a gram-negative bacteria or
a gram-posa bacteria so if we're dealing
with gram-negative it mainly goes after
the DNA gyrase enzyme so it's going to
disrupt how this strand is able to not
be super coiled so if we can prevent
this process of it helping the super
coiled part of the DNA strand we're
going to prevent it from being able to
go further in this replication process
hence killing our bacteria now if we're
dealing with a gram-positive Act area
and mainly wants to inhibit this
topoisomerase IV so it's going to
prevent these daughter DNA strands from
separating from itself they can't
separate we can't get DNA replication
hence we get dead bacteria now let's
talk about the nurse's role for
administering quinolones so before you
administer you want to just confirm your
patient is not allergic to this
medication and then during
Administration you want to make sure
that this medication is being effective
is it actually treating your patient and
are they getting better for instance how
are their temperatures are they hypo or
hyperthermic that's not good how's their
white blood cell count is it normal or
is it really elevated remember a normal
white blood cell count is anywhere
between five to ten thousand also how do
they look how's their Vital Signs is
their blood pressure really low are they
hypotensive are they tachycardic are
they having mental status changes
breathing problems all this could
indicate that your patient may be
experiencing septic shock talk so you
want to monitor for those things now in
addition to that you want to make sure
you also know things to educate your
patient about and things you need to
watch out for in your patient whenever
they're taking these medications so to
help us remember those main Concepts
we're going to remember the mnemonic
floxacens F is for fluid intake to
prevent Crystal
urea and this can especially happen with
ciprofloxacin so you want to educate the
patient to take this with at least eight
ounces of water and to drink fluids
throughout the day because we want to
prevent crystals from developing within
the urinary system because with Crystal
urea this can happen whenever the urine
becomes too alkaline and if we get the
development of crystals it can cause a
blockage in the kidneys and it could
lead to renal failure so as the nurse
you want to make sure you're monitoring
your patient's hydration status so if
it's not contraindicated they need at
least two liters of fluid per day and
you want to be monitoring that urinary
output now as a side note whenever
you're studying the other antibiotics
this is also a teaching point with the
sulfonamides as well the crystal urea L
is for Long QT interval so quinolones
can prolong the QT interval and whenever
this happens it can lead to a lethal
Rhythm called torsoids to plant and
there's an increased risk of the patient
getting a prolonged QT interval if
they're taking aquinolone along with
another medication that prolongs the QT
interval like an antiarhythmic like
amioderm so as a nurse you want to be
looking at that ECG measuring that QT
interval making sure it falls within
normal limits O is for older adults 60
or older because they are at risk for
tendon inflammation and rupture
especially with the Achilles tendon
being involved so you want to educate
the patient to immediately report any
pain swelling or like this snap feeling
or immobility that they may be
experiencing around a tendon now this is
particularly important if your patient
is taking corticosteroids or they have a
history of diabetes or renal issues
because there is a more increased chance
of this happening in that older adult
and then X is for don't administer with
medications that contain cations like
calcium zinc iron magnesium and aluminum
now these are Big ingredients in
antacids and vitamins and you also don't
want to give this with dairy products
like milk cheese or yogurt because all
of these can actually decrease the
absorption of oral quinolones so as a
nurse you want to remember to administer
oral quinolones two hours before or
after meals and administer oral
quinolone six hours after administering
antacids or vitamins containing the
ingredients I just went over or two
hours before an antacid by doing this
this will help decrease the risk of
altering the absorption of that
quinolone a is to avoid quinolones in
children and during pregnancy it's been
found that quinolones can cause bone and
cartilage problems in children and then
C is for C diff this is actually a super
infection that occurs in the gut that
can happen from taking quinolones so you
want to educate your patient and monitor
your patient for any type of fever
watery diarrhea or abdominal pain and if
they do have this you want to report it
to the physician who will order a
culture of the stool to send it off to
make sure the patient hasn't developed C
diff and then there's eye for
interactions you want to be familiar
with the medications that could
interfere with quinolone so the big ones
are like caffeine phenytonin Warfarin
Theophylline and amioderone then we have
in for neuromuscular exacerbation so you
really want to monitor patients who have
myasthenia gravis because quinolones can
actually make the condition worse so
you'd want to be monitoring for muscle
weakness and then lastly is s for sun
sensitivity so quinolones can make this
skin more susceptible to Burns and
blistering from the sunlight's Rays so
you want to educate the patient that
this can happen while they're taking the
medication and for several days
afterward so they want to take measures
to protect their skin whenever they're
Outdoors so they don't get these adverse
effects okay so that wraps up this video
over quinolones and don't forget to
access the free quiz in the YouTube
description that will test your
knowledge on this material